tomás tiene 400 barras de caramelo en su
tienda y cada una cuesta 0.50 pesos muy
bien sea pdv el precio el precio por
supuesto denotamos con la letra p medido
en pesos de la compra de barras de
caramelo muy bien esencialmente nos está
diciendo que el precio es una función
del número de barras de caramelo que
vayamos a comprar verdad de hecho pues
pd se puede calcular fácilmente como el
número de barras que en este caso es b x
0.50 pero bueno no vamos a utilizar ese
hecho en este vídeo luego nos dice o nos
pregunta más bien qué tipo de número es
más apropiado para el dominio de la
función y nos dan dos opciones enteros o
números reales finalmente nos dice que
hay que definir el intervalo del dominio
así que vamos a resolver esta primera
pregunta nos dice qué tipo de número es
más apropiado por el dominio de la
función
y recordemos que el dominio es el
conjunto de valores de entrada en donde
la función está bien definida verdad y
aquí los valores de entrada están denota
dos con la letra b y son barras de
caramelo lo cual nos dice que digamos el
tipo del número más apropiado son entero
es verdad porque vamos a nosa ya lo
mejor en una en esta tienda quizás
tradicional su podemos pedir una barra
dos barras tres barras diez barras de
caramelo sin embargo no podemos pedir
por ejemplo nose 3.72 barras de caramelo
verdad o no podemos pedir y barras de
caramelo o raíz de dos barras de
caramelo en realidad vamos a ir pidiendo
podemos comprar una más o una menos así
que vamos a considerar solo números
enteros
ahora nos preguntan definir el intervalo
del dominio entonces en realidad desde
cuánto desde cuántas barras de caramelo
podemos comprar y cuál sería el máximo
número
de barras de caramelo que podemos
comprar y en realidad podríamos comprar
0 barras de caramelo verdad y aquí
tenemos dos opciones podemos incluir el
0 o excluir el 0 sin embargo vamos a
incluir el 0 verdad podríamos no comprar
barras de caramelo y simplemente no
gastar ahora cuál sería el valor máximo
de barras de caramelo que podríamos
comprar y aquí nos dice que la tienda
solo tiene 400 barras de caramelo así
que no podemos comprar más de 400 barras
de caramelo sin embargo si podemos
comprar las todas verdad esas 400 si
podemos comprarlas no sé a lo mejor
vamos a hacer una fiesta o algo así así
que el intervalo del dominio sería 0,400
incluyendo al 0 y también al 400 y es
correcto